EASILY CLEARED THE SENATE AND
THE HOUSE.
BRET.
>> Bret: PETER DOOCY LIVE ON
THE HILL.
THANK YOU.
NOT A FULL DISMANTLE OF
DODD-FRANK BUT A BIG WIN FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
VOTERS ARE GOING TO THE POLLS IN
TEXAS, ARKANSAS, KENTUCKY,
GEORGIA.
CORRESPONDED JONATHAN SERRIE'S
IN GAINESVILLE, GEORGIA, RIGHT
NOW WITH AN INTENSE BATTLE AMONG
REPUBLICANS BUYING FOR SPOT ON
THE GUBERNATORIAL TICKET THERE.
GOOD EVENING, JONATHAN.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
I AM AT THE CASEY CAGLE WATCH
PARTY.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ENJOYS
STATEWIDE NAME RECOGNITION BUT
HE'S 1 OF 5 G.O.P. CANDIDATES IN
THE PRIMARY.
A JULY RUNOFF APPEARS
INCREASINGLY LIKELY IN THIS
RACE.
THE OTHER STATEWIDE OFFICE
HOLDER IN THE REPUBLICAN RACE
FOR GOVERNOR, GEORGIA SECRETARY
OF STATE BRIAN KEMP.
HE GAINED NATIONAL ATTENTION
WITH SOME PROVOCATIVE ADS TO
SHOW HIS SUPPORT FOR THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
FORMER NAVY SEAL CLAY TIPPIN'S
AND FORMER ARMY RANGER HUNTER
HILL HAVE BEEN TOUTING THEIR
MILITARY EXPENSE AND STATE
SENATOR MICHAEL WILLIAMS EARNED
PRAISE AND PROTEST WHEN HE
BRANDED HIS CAMPAIGN BUS
AS A DEPORTATION BUS.
HE SAYS HE DID THAT TO RAISE THE
ISSUE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
FOR REPUBLICANS IN THIS PRIMARY,
THE STRATEGY HAS BEEN ENERGIZING
THE POPULIST CONSERVATIVE BASE.
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY FOR
GEORGIA GOVERNOR, TWO CANDIDATES
WITH THE SAME FIRST NAME AND
SIMILAR PLATFORMS WENT INTO THIS
RACE WITH SOME VERY DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES.
STATE REPRESENTATIVE STACEY
EVANS WHOSE DISTRICT IS LOCATED
IN THE ATLANTA SUBURB, TRYING TO
WIN BACK SUBURBAN MODERATES AND
WORKING-CLASS VOTERS WHO HAVE
LEFT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
LARGE NUMBERS.
FORMER STATE REPRESENTATIVE
STACY ABRAMS HAS BEEN RUNNING A
DOOR-TO-DOOR CAMPAIGN TO ATTRACT
NEW VOTERS WITH LEFT-LEANING
VALUES.
YESTERDAY ABRAMS PICKED UP THE
SUPPORT OF HILLARY CLINTON, WHO
RECORDED A ROBO CALL FOR HER.
SHE HAS THE ENDORSEMENT OF
SENATORS KAMALA HARRIS,
CORY BOOKER, AND BERNIE SANDERS.
BRET, TONIGHT DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO BE WATCHING TONIGHT'S
PRIMARY TO SEE WHICH OF THOSE
TWO STRATEGIES RESONATES MOST
WITH VOTERS AND THEN YOU WILL
LIKELY SEE THAT STRATEGY IN
FUTURE CAMPAIGNS GOING INTO THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
FOR REPUBLICANS, BECAUSE OF THE
SHEER NUMBER OF G.O.P.
CONTENDERS, THIS RACE MAY NOT BE
DECIDED TONIGHT.
ANALYSTS SAY THE CAMPAIGN FOR A
RUNOFF ELECTION FOR THE G.O.P.
COULD BE BOTH NASTY AND VERY